oh
and it grows and it grows and it grows
that one is a lot
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we open up season 17 with seth
rogen he's an actor and filmmaker who's
been a leading and very busy comedic
presence in hollywood for damn near 20
years he has a pair of highly
anticipated projects on the way
including the hulu limited series pam
and tommy which is set to release on
february 2nd as well as the boys
presents diabolical an animated
anthology series set in the universe of
the emmy-nominated hit series the boys
premiering exclusively on prime video
march 4th seth rogen welcome back to the
show thanks for having me and then this
is now your third time doing hot ones
this is rarefied air on this show what's
going through your head as you prepare
to dig in
um something you said i think i was with
other people both other times charlize
and dominic yeah and i think the first
time i'm doing 10 so
eating 10 hot wings for me is not
generally like a big deal so i guess
we'll see how it goes
i'm excited i'm looking forward to it
[Music]
okay just go just go
[Music]
it's good
easy
[Music]
so to open things up with pam and tommy
a series that documents the pamela
anderson tommy lee hollywood video that
was famously stolen by a disgruntled
contractor and then leaked to the
internet how do you quantify the
significance of the pam and tommy sex
tape like could a case be made that an
internet show like this might not even
exist if not for the tectonic shift that
happened after that video napalm the
internet
um
yeah i think there's a
line that could be drawn between like
just watching things on the internet and
that tape it's one of the first
things that like was
consumed in mass online in video form
the ingenuity that went into people
trying to disseminate that tape even
though it was very wrong of them is
something that we all ultimately live in
the shadow of you know
my wife isn't good with hot food so i
gage everything of like would i tell my
wife this is too hot to eat and i don't
think i think one just okay yeah totally
fine what are you ready to move on to
the second one it's actually from canada
oh special for you seth cedar smoked
garlic hot sauce
if you may use dale
[Music]
and actually kind of a spicy number two
you must be familiar with those
that is a spicy number two though it is
[Laughter]
so as you mentioned up top you have the
boys diabolical coming soon to prime
video as someone who was once described
by gq as the patron saint of disturbing
comics what sorts of things
do you look for in a comic book source
material that make you think this would
make a good tv show or movie
something like the boys was just like
very it was obvious to us you know and
it's a funny journey with the comic
because like me and evan my partner like
we're big fans of garth ennis who wrote
the comic hero preacher as well and we
bought the first issue right when it
came out i remember we were like oh my
god this would be like such a great
movie like
kind of regular people fighting
superheroes you know um
we brought it to sony and neil maritz
the producer and they were like yeah
this would make an incredible movie
um we'll buy the rights to it and then
they did and then they did not hire us
to write it or produce it in any way
shape or form they hired other people to
do that and after
like a decade of those people just like
[ __ ] it up in some way shape or form
it like came back to us basically and
then we turned it into the tv show
i think people love superhero stuff and
marvel's obviously very popular and
makes great films and and tv shows but
there are certain things they just can't
do like it would simply be
you know it would simply be too damaging
to their brand to have like a character
kill someone with a 10-foot dick so as
long as they are not doing that it
leaves a great opportunity for for us to
do that
[Music]
calabria
ooh
continental
so you've appeared on the burger show
multiple times i know that you're a
connoisseur when it comes to the
religion of burger cheese meat and bun
can you explain your theory that thick
patties are for [ __ ]
i just you know
and i said that i'd say before the like
smash burger craze kind of took over
which was a validating thing to happen
in the wake of that statement but
yeah i just ooh it went into my throat
i just didn't love uh
i just don't love these thick patties
that started sweeping the nation
and i love like a crispy burger like a
thin crispy burger and i would also
rather eat more small burgers than one
big burger but my being on that show led
me to judge a hamburger competition
where over the course of course of one
night i ate like 50 hamburgers uh for
the la food and wine festival i think it
was and it was truly like one of the
greatest days of my entire life uh it
was wonderful well you're welcome for
that yes
[Music]
a little spicy
[Music]
i caught the pepper i think i caught the
pepper i can see from your face you're
catching the pepperoni yeah
lighten up over here
yeah ooh
catching the pepper
so your preference for making films for
a low enough budget that nobody bothers
to come and check in on what's going on
it really resonated with us here at this
show because that's more or less the
history of hot ones yeah why is 25 to 35
million dollars for you the ideal amount
of money to make a movie
i mean
that's what it's been and i'd say that
is shifting like i'd say with the last
few years have greatly
they've made it much harder especially
for comedies we've been lucky in that
we've made a few over the last few years
but traditionally that has been a number
that makes us a studio film but never
one of their bigger movies and they're
always off making like you know as we're
making blockers they're making like fast
and furious eight so it's like
they're not worried about us because
like vin diesel will come out of his
dressing room and it's costing them like
10 million dollars a day or some [ __ ]
like that so like our whole movie is
like less than vin diesel waste on the
average
like afternoon on a fast and furious
film and so uh as a result of that they
generally um leave us alone
in your experience of pitching scripts
what have you found to be the most
enticing or persuasive selling points to
make to a studio
to a studio if it's like
easy
a movie like neighbors like that sold
very easily it's like oh like we're a
couple with a new baby we miss partying
we live next to a fraternity house like
you know
you don't have to be a genius to see how
that would like be a broad uh appeal you
know what i mean but even something like
like sausage party like no one wanted to
make you know and super bad knowing what
day pilot express no one wanted to make
so like what's nice is now that we
like now we can make like a teenage
mutant ninja turtles movie but we're
also trying to make like insane things
that no one wants to
touch and it's nice that we can kind of
work in in both worlds a little bit you
know
[Music]
okay this is your own hot one sauce yeah
but if you work on did you formulate
this a little bit no i wasn't like in a
bathtub
[Music]
mixing it up right now i don't want to
eat it
bathtub hot sauce but if you don't like
it seth
let me know you will take it personally
[Music]
very good
i'm not catching the pepper in the same
way on this one as i was the previous
one i feel like this lineup
it's kind of a gift
i don't know what to expect it's bobbing
and weaving a little bit
this one's less hot than the previous
one right like i assume a little point
where it's all just like insanity and
excruciating pain so it won't matter
anymore that's coming up that's coming
up but in the meantime seth we have a
crane segment on our show called explain
that graham we're doing a deep dive on
our guest instagram poll interesting
pictures that need more context so we'll
pull up the picture over here on the
monitor yeah you just tell us the bigger
story how big a thrill was it for you to
share a performance of young wild and
free with snoop dogg
yeah this was uh hilarity for charity
which is a alzheimer's organization that
me and my wife and some friends uh
founded and one year snoop dogg was the
headliner
and uh he auctioned off a blunt for ten
thousand dollars which was
uh i would say probably not a lot of
alzheimer's organizations can make that
claim
um but we can uh it was amazing you like
every like on a pretty regular basis
find yourself in a situation where you
smoke weed with snoop dogg and that is
like
as far as like life you know signs your
life isn't going terribly go that's
that's a good one
all right up next
of all your vintage ashtrays that you
own is there one that you describe as a
holy grail
this one is a pretty rare one and a
pretty hard to find one is uh
[Music]
cause i think they're like hand-painted
louis vuitton uh and hand like glazed
ceramic louis vuitton ashtrays there's
not a ton of them i haven't seen a lot
of them so that one is pretty nice i
think it's from the 50s or 60s or
something like that well what i actually
got really fascinated by was like what
companies used to make ashtrays so i own
a lot of like disney ashtrays because i
think it's funny that disney used to
make ashtrays the government made ash i
own a bunch of nasa ashtrays because
nasa said ashtrays i own some from like
the department of defense like things
like that the fbi like they had ash
trailing if you went to the fbi in the
70s there was ashtrays there you know
and their own like branded ashtrays so
uh i became fascinated there's i have a
post serial ashtray and like a 7-up ash
tray like
i just kind of became fascinated by like
who made ashtrays um at various points
uh in their history so yeah that that
was a weird rabbit hole
i've been going down
[Music]
coco ghost
okay
how often do you like rub your eyes or
something
well
i've done it enough to where now i'm
like paranoid about it
i like felt that one of my ears
i could hear it but thanks for pointing
that out because usually i'm just like
all over our guests to be like
careful around the eyes careful on the
eyes my friend was saying he was doing
the hot wings challenge on new year's
and he uh got some in his pee hole oh
it's uh occupational
it happens any sort of uh
cross-pollination hot sauce problem that
you can have i've had
i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry
so you've added a wrinkle into the
definition of pothead by getting into
ceramics recently comparing it to a
meditative hobby like yoga except that
you get a vase at the end of your bikram
session yeah do you have a go-to glaze
recipe
um i do have a go-to glaze recipe that
um
i kind of formulated on my own so i'm
not not that it would mean
but it includes magnesium carbonate is
one of the main ingredients and that's
what causes the glazes to glop up like
my glazes do and they have these like
they're very bumpy and textural and you
get better at it which is nice because i
can't necessarily say that about
everything else i do in life except for
karate
the back of the class and then to the
top you know
just don't quit that's the theme that's
the theme so just don't quit and
speaking of
speaking of
not quitting
fortunately jacqueline hyde
13 angry scorpion jeffrey freakishly hot
[Music]
oh ooh
but going back in i mean you got to
finish them right can't stop won't stop
[Music]
my head is starting to sweat
oh yeah out of somewhere weird i like i
i
i can't definitely say sweat has ever
come from that part or it might be a
tear i don't know if it's sweater or a
deer liquid is coming from my head and
i'm afraid to wipe it away because my
ass
is it true that the roller coaster
montage and knocked up was one of the
most difficult to shoot because jay
baershaw has a paranoia the fear of
roller coasters also they make you puke
yes
that day was [ __ ] up
and
i think it's in the movie jake's having
like a full on panic attack yeah he's
not acting no he's not acting he's like
get me out get me out of this [ __ ]
thing
and then the rest of us
had to ride it like
[ __ ] ten more times or some [ __ ] like
that and we're doing the [ __ ] falling
thing
jay was like having a nervous breakdown
like jason was on oxygen i was like half
passed out half vomiting on dramamine
all day so yeah is it true that uh one
of the seminal scenes of 5050 where
joseph gordon-levitt's character adam is
shaving his head that that was uh
improvised you guys were improvising the
characters as the cameras were still
rolling yes
that was uh that was high stakes improv
yeah i'd say in the pantheon of head
shaving scenes gi jane empire records 50
50. put it on the mountain
my own saliva just betrayed me
[Laughter]
it reminds me like once i had to film in
like a blizzard in my mouth our like
mouths froze and we couldn't talk that
that's what that's what's happening
right now the opposite yeah okay but
regaling me with the great side
i'm trying to take my mind
[Music]
that one
that's a lot
like when i was telling you it never
gets any easier there's nothing this is
the kind of thing that you like this
morning when you wake up you're just
like i know at some point today this is
gonna happen to me
it's a fun job you like it except for
except for this part yeah you know they
all have their pitfalls and it grows and
it grows and it grows
that one is a lot
i'm like sweating and i'm afraid to take
off my dusters because i'm like afraid
even of like the proximity of my
my head to my head my head to my back i
can't talk
so
i know that you're a student of comedy
film and you mar one of your favorites
is the last detail the 1973 how ashby
directed film starring jack nicholson
yeah
what did you mean by it's always about
the joke it's never about the camera
moves
oh
i think
i think for comedy
and it's something i grapple with a lot
is that like
you know when you i think as a filmmaker
when you make things your instinct is to
make them look fancy and i think
the conundrum is at times for comedy the
less fancy it looks the funnier it is
and the more simple it is the funnier it
is that was a close call when i just
and so
south park should never be able to be as
funny as like a pixar movie because it
doesn't look as good but that's not how
it is like
i think doesn't need to look good to be
very funny and at times honestly like
the worse by
some conventional standards the thing
looks the funnier it is i'm not dying my
lips are burning
me too
i looked like a little chap all day
today i was like oh no that's gonna be
such a bummer later i feel like i have
like a an inch of standing water in my
left eye
i can't wipe it
this next one
is the pucker butt
great
that's what you're secretly thinking
whenever you're eating this stuff is how
will this make my ass feel and the
pucker butt brand was they spilled
enough to be like we'll [ __ ] tell you
it's it'll make your [ __ ] really hurt
that was a funny noise yeah you just
prepare yourself okay
[Music]
okay
very hot
but after the last one not as
still very hot though yeah this one's
making my gums hurt they keep trying new
parts of my mouth when they hurt i keep
being like that's the whole mouth but no
checking all the boxes checking all the
boxes
so one of your first big breaks was a
writing job on the ali g show and
recently that you tweeted that sasha
baron cohen is the only person i know
who truly risks his life for his art
during your time on the show do you ever
recall an instance of being worried
about his well-being during a shoot yes
lots of times
we went to spring break kind of messing
with really drunk aggro frat guys
there was a point where sasha had to
like run away
no i keep like snorting forgetting that
i'm just like sending like a
concentrated rocket of
hot sauce saliva
so yeah he would go and shoot all day
and then come back
and like show us the footage basically
and remember that was one where like he
was almost getting killed and he ran
away
but he was wearing his mic uh and so you
could still hear him and he stayed in
character the whole time and he was
bruno
the whole time he's like they're gonna
kill me they're gonna kill me and he's
like hiding in a shop he's like sorry
like and you hear him like talking to
the shop owner like asking if he could
hide and like
he never broke character the entire time
but he like was legitimately running uh
out of fear for his
his well-being
speaking of of fear
it's time for the final sauce
and going into sauce 10 will be joined
by a very special guest evan
do they have his own wing way to blow
the surprise sorry hey you can edit it
out
you control this footage
[Music]
all right for wing 10 we have a very
special guest screenwriter producer
director evan goldberg you guys have
been collaborators since you're
literally kids and now look at us tag
teaming the last dab together should we
eat off the same wing
your choice your choice we each have our
own let's stick together but before that
it's tradition around here to put a
little extra on the last one you don't
have to
my head feels crazy
yeah
i truly feel insane like
i feel i feel nuts
you look normal than you think you might
thank god
my mouth is burning
[Music]
i'm literally thinking like do i have
any other things i'm supposed to do
today because i don't think i can do
them
we're writing a book together oh yeah
nothing better to prime your mind it'll
do exactly it'll shake the ideas loose
over here
cheers guys cheers
[Music]
normally when i see people on this they
say like i don't feel anything at first
it instantly hurts yeah
well evan
you're not here
you know eating the wing you know you're
just on a straight
vertical ramp up right now feels like i
am
oh it hurts my lips real bad
the lip pain is by far the worst part
i'm sweating so much my glasses are like
sliding down my head but so careful yeah
his hand hurts over there it is
beautiful to watch a sight to behold
this tastes great
i am into this i need to soak my lips in
the milk i need to eat more of this evan
we got a bottle for you to go we've got
a bottle for you to go this was a great
this was a great quick visit i'm so
happy right now and congratulations to
the both of you conquering the wings of
death today maybe this is a surprise to
seth but at this point i'm gonna turn
the show over to evan to ask seth a
question that only a close childhood
friend could know only an intimate
wingtime conclusion to the season 17
premiere of hot ones okay here's what i
got okay
seth has done many brave things on
camera off camera you've been a brave
partner
in our business endeavors that's nice
but there was a time in 10th grade when
you did one of the least brave things
i've ever seen someone do oh no
it was in tawasan
do you have any
recollection
of perhaps the moment i'm referring to i
do remember this and it was a cowardly
maneuver
and it was like that if you were my
friend i would always look at me a
little differently after it took like a
decade but i'm over it
we were uh
tawassen
let's start with tawasan that's the name
of a town delos is a place in like 40
minutes outside of vancouver oh my god
it's like working its way along my lips
and spreading on the inside of my mouth
um and uh
they had a giant paintball facility like
a huge outdoor paintball facility and we
all went paintballing there
and these guys showed up that were like
professional paintball guys we're like
15 years old
and
they're [ __ ] loaded with paintball
bullets and they have like automatic
paintball guns we have like the pump
action cheap shitty payments we didn't
know like what their guns could do no
they right away from my memory just like
[ __ ] unload like a torrent of like
like a machine gun
and i run off into the woods as
literally all my friends get annihilated
yeah these men were like i got shot 25
times in the back then you must have
been alone in the woods
like we did it guys we got away i looked
back and i was all alone
that was like oh like we all got hurt
like i was covered in welts oh yeah they
were like bleeding and then i came back
and everyone was really pissed at me
they were like what did you like you
[ __ ] cowards
and you bailed on all of us it's been
uphill from since then i had to earn
back their trust well you know what
that's good to know and evan i hope that
this was cathartic for you to hear that
story from me away i mean just like this
heat is eating my gum line oh it is it
feels like it worked into my teeth
but you know what you made it through
seth evan you made it through you
reached the finish line conquered the
wings of death now for the third time
hang that rogan jersey in the rafters
and now there's nothing left to do but
roll out the red carpet for you seth
this camera this camera this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life
we have uh the boys presents diabolical
which is an animated anthology series um
in the universe of the boys it's i don't
know if you ever heard of the animatrix
that was the series of short animated
films they released when the matrix
films came out well we ripped off that
yeah the only little twist we have is
there's like eight different creative
entities behind each of them and we do
one and we have justin roiland doing one
and aquafina so it's like a real wild
mixed bag and the animation's really
different every time yeah they're all
really insane and wonderful and february
2nd pam and tommy comes to hulu i my
brain is not my brain has been
infiltrated by peppers
we did it great job
my body it sounds like your system into
shock a little bit yeah no sometimes i
do straight up like walk out of here
like not feeling my feet with like some
light-headed action have you talked to a
doctor about the long-term possible
ramifications of kids you know what you
know what's funny about that is uh no
you know what funny is i'm afraid to
hey spice lords what's going on camera
guy bill here hope you enjoyed that
episode of hot ones keep telling us your
favorite moments quotes and episodes in
the comments below and let us know who
you want to see on hot ones camera guy
build perhaps and don't forget to smash
that subscribe button and like the video
to stay up to date to the latest and
greatest hot ones news in 2022 there are
a lot of exciting things coming and you
don't want to miss it this is camera guy
bill here saying it's good to be camera
guy bill
[Music]